[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAWRENCE: Hi, and welcome
again to GeoCasts,
where we'll teach you all about
using Google Maps to build
better apps.
I'm Lawrence, and
in this video I'm
going to talk all about building
an interactive place-based
experience using the Places API.
It's a simple game, and you'll
be communicating with Alyssa,
this woman who's trapped
in a parallel dimension,
and well, I'll just let her
explain what you have to do.
ALYSSA: There was an accident.
I'm trapped in an alternate
dimension which is literally
right next door to yours.
Parts of my dimension
are leaking into yours,
and if you can get
to their location,
I can fix it and
get myself home.
LAWRENCE: So how does
this work as an app?
It's been made user customizable
so you can pick any three
places in the world,
assign a code to them,
and then when you share
that code with your friends,
Alyssa will guide them
through those three places
to solve puzzles that
will get her home.
The Google Places API supports
over 100 million places
around the world so you
have lots to choose from.
Here you can see
some games that I've
designed stored in Firebase.
So for example, if you were
to use the code googkior,
you'd go to these three
places to rescue Alyssa.
Or if you were to
choose the code draheda,
you'd be guided to these three.
The Places API has a
user interface widget
called the PlacePicker, which
allows you to pick your desired
places off the map.
In this video, you'll see how
to use the PlacePicker to choose
your three places and how
to store them in Firebase.
In the next video
in this series,
we'll look at how you
use the Places API
to detect your current
location to see if it matches
the desired place.
As it uses real world
places, the Places API
is a terrific way to make
it user-friendly, powerful,
and easy to build for.
ALYSSA: It's really nice
of you to help me out.
Thanks.
LAWRENCE: You're welcome.
The Places API is designed
to make your apps stand out
with detailed information
about over 100 million places
around the world, across a
wide range of categories,
and it uses the same
database as Google Maps.
Not only that, the Places
API has place detection,
giving you the ability
to tell if your user is
in one of those locations.
ALYSSA: That makes it easier.
I can just tell you to go
to a specific location,
like say, the Seattle
Space Needle, instead
of dealing with latitude
and longitude or addresses.
LAWRENCE: That's right.
And the Places
API, remember, can
detect if your user is there.
ALYSSA: Well, of course
I'm there, silly.
LAWRENCE: Right, but before we
get to detecting the places,
let's look at how we
can build an app where
you can configure the places
that you want to play in.
We'll use the PlacePicker
control to pick three places
and store their
place IDs in Firebase
along with a unique code.
You can share that
code with your friends
so when they play
the game, Alyssa
will tell them to go to
those places, like this.
ALYSSA: The first part is here.
Please go and I'll let you
know once you're close enough.
LAWRENCE: The
PlacePicker control
allows me to give my end users
a standard, user-friendly way
of selecting the places that
this game will be played in.
So for the game, I decided
that it would use three places.
You can see how it works here.
Every time I press
a button, I get
the PlacePicker, along
with Google Maps,
allowing me to choose a place.
I'll pick the Space
Needle for us.
You're still there
right, Alyssa?
ALYSSA: Roger that.
LAWRENCE: Good.
So then I can pick
some other places.
ALYSSA: And if you really
don't like your friends,
you can make them locations
that are really far away, right?
LAWRENCE: That's right.
And of course, as
you can see here,
these strings are
the identifiers
for those places on Google.
Later when we scan for
the device location,
we'll find nearby places
and we can compare
to see if we're close to these.
So how does this work in code?
First of all, in order
to use the PlacePicker,
you need your app to
have the access find
location permission, so
make sure you have that.
Docs on how to do
that are right here.
Next, make sure you
have the location
libraries from Play Services
included in your builder
gradle.
Now, in an Android
activity, and as you
can see mine is called
Create Game Activity,
you can use a PlacePicker
Intent Builder
to create a PlacePicker intent.
Start this and the
picker will run for you.
If you're wondering what
that ID parameter is,
this game allows you
to define three places,
so it's just an integer
for one, two, or three.
Once the user selects a place,
OnActivityResult will fire
and it will contain an intent
with the returned data.
You can then turn this
into a place object with
the PlacePicker
.getplacefunction.
The place object exposes
the Google identifier
for that location as the
place ID, which you can then
read with that method.
It also has the
description for the place
which you can access
with a place.getname
and cast that into a string.
It's really that simple.
To close the loop,
here's how you
can save the three Place IDs
to Firebase under a game code.
I simply create a node
with the game code
and store these
values under that.
Do note that there
are restrictions
to saving data from the Places
API in your own database.
Before distributing an app
that uses the Places API,
be sure to understand
the policies.
They're linked right here.
So you've completed the
first part of this task.
Well done.
In the next video,
we'll take a look
at how to use the Places API
to determine if your users are
close enough to the
desired place to unlock
the next part of the game.
You can learn more about the
Google Places API at this page
and see more GeoCasts videos on
the Google Developers channel.
ALYSSA: And don't forget to
hit that Subscribe button.
[MUSIC PLAYING]